I want to give Jack a great send-off a
meal to really remember so I'm making my
giant burger yeah it's going to be
massive time for the party
I'm gonna start by chopping up this
onion always be careful with your sharp
knives I think Jack's going to really
miss home cooked food cry
that's the onions making me cry advice
you're not the thought of missing Jack
onions always make me cry
next chop garlic and fry in olive oil
with the onions then add to your beef
mince I'm putting some chili sauce you
don't need to add it but Jack loves it
give it a bit of a mix around add pepper
and salt then fry in olive oil I'm just
gonna mash this down to make it even
this is going to do one massive burger
get your favorite toppings ready
instead of putting lettuce on I'm
changing it up a bit and putting
watercress it's a bit of a water theme
as Jack's go on a water photo tour now
it's time to flip the burger but because
it's so big I'm going to get my dad to
help dad that's had a bad sports injury
so he's on crutches I would like you to
please help me flip it onto those plates
and then get it back in the pan really
careful that on there first and then a
little cloth in case any juice falls out
1 2 3 and turn beautiful that can what
you've never seen a burger this way I
made my giant bun with flour yeast salt
oil and water hmm and I'm getting the
expert to cut it
no no no I'll just cut it a little bit
an email sorry
while your rubbish dad corrects his bad
bun cutting put mozzarella on the burger
to melt okay it's not a great idea to
rub your bun on dad's head now I think
your work is done
yeah toast your bun these are all Jack's
favorite sauces mustard ketchup
mayonnaise
then add gherkins sliced tomatoes and
the watercress next put on the huge
patty slider in a bit of time Wow looks
[Music]
that's nice interested mmm gotta get a
snap of this and that looks amazing